My son has Lyme. How can I help navigate this journey?
That's pretty deep question
because it really depends on what phase of Lyme there is. So if you're there in the acute phase, I'm sure you're talking about chronic phase Lyme here, not in a acute phase Lyme.
But in a chronic phase Lyme and in a startup of acute phase Lyme, basically follow the instructions on the Lyme course.
You would consider getting a doctor locally where you could get a prescription of antibiotics in a chronic phase.
Antibiotics can help somewhat as well, but you really need to start getting your immune system to try to help kill this.
That's where a rife can be beneficial. And then in phase three if you're in an autoimmune phase, that's a whole different
follow-ups, hold it for a way you have to treat it because you're basically at that point, bandaging it, treating it.
So follow everything that's on the Lyme course. If you're on the Lyme course, if you're not on the Lyme course, you really want to do it in the Lyme course because it gets tricky.
Now we'll have the autoimmune course done with a matter of time here to that will help as well.
But people make major mistakes when they're treating chronic Lyme if they are in an autoimmune phase.
And that can give them a lot of symptoms that they call herc cyber reaction symptoms.
But many times they're not even herc cyber reaction symptoms. It's that you're you're getting damage to self tissue if you have self.
Antibodies back to that autoimmune question. If you have self antibodies to self tissue and you're giving a lot of immune
stimulants and you're at a TH1 dominant condition, you could actually be making yourself worse and helping your immune system kill your
body. So you do want to investigate if you've been especially if you've experienced worse symptoms trying to take immune
stimulants. And it all goes against contrary thought. It's contrary to your typical thought that I have a
mild toxin, I want to kill it. So I'm going to take all these immune stimulants to kill it, but I feel worse. Maybe it's just
die off. Maybe, but more than likely if this is happening a lot or you're not getting any better. If you have
antibodies to self tissue and you're stimulating the immune response and you're at a TH1 dominant
already, you will fire or you will kill that when you have antibodies against first, which is the
self tissue. And you can make yourself worse because you're just damaging yourself. So you don't want
to you have to back off those immune stimulants and you have to try to deal with this another way and comb
down that inflammatory response, stimulate on what are called T-regulate ourselves, which helps balance
the immune system. And if you still have an active antigen or an active pathogen, you want to do
things to kill it that won't be using your immune system and that's where the right question for the